people are naturally inherently mobile
and yet for a hundred years we had been
told that the only way to communicate
was over a pair of wires wires that kind
of leased you to your desk that tied you
to your home when you wanted the freedom
to be everywhere and that is the nature
of what communications ought to be
portable means freedom
in the late 1960s I was at Motorola but
at that time if you wanted a phone the
only way to get it was from AT&T in most
places and they would even sell it to
you you would have to run it from and
they invented a concept called
cellular telephony they announced that
they were going to set people free they
were going to cut the wire and the
second thing that they said is this
service is going to be car telephones as
a vehicle drives from one cell to
another advanced electronic equipment
automatically transfers the call by
telephone line to another cell without
the caller knowing it that's when I had
the idea of why don't we build a
cellular system that's the way it ought
to be that's personal portable we shut
down engineering in the company and put
all our efforts into building a handheld
portable cell phone
on April 3rd 1973 we actually
demonstrated the system in New York we
had a press conference scheduled for the
afternoon but we had been approached by
journalists and I decided well why don't
we give him a real demonstration a real
demonstration would be walking down the
street and that's exactly what we did I
wanted to really put ahead dazzling
demonstration on for this journalism I
took a chance and called Joel Engel dr.
Engel was running the AT&T program and I
said hi Joel its cardi Cooper hi Marty
he says coming I'm calling you from a
cell phone but a real soulful personal
handheld portable shelf over there were
silence at the other end of the line to
this day Joel doesn't remember that call
and I'm not sure I blame them this is an
exact model of the very first cell phone
there were only two phones in existence
at that time the biggest issue in that
first call we didn't know it was going
to be historic in any way at all
we were only worried about one thing is
the phone go to work when we turn it on
fortunately it did
we never could have predicted what has
happened to the technology over the
years since we created that first cell
phone now the modern smartphone is a
technological marvel it really is
incredible all that stuff that is
squeezed into that cell phone but I'm
not very happy with it a part of it
because we think that we could make a
smart phone that does all things for all
people and yet we know that it doesn't
do any of those things perfectly so
we've still got a ways to go